foreign
[Music]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
specifically your money your work your
relationships I'm Kidd Coleman joined by
Jade warshaw this hour we're gonna have
some fun of no the number to jump in is
triple eight eight two five five two two
five that's triple eight eight two five
five two two five and Jade uh it's uh
the last show this week but boy we've
had quite a week we have as we look back
on the week we've had some really great
calls about investing and the strategy
to win in Investments
um and that roller coaster do I time the
market or am I the tortoise right to
stay on the course uh we even had
industry call about a thousand dollars
in the emergency fund is that enough
and you've walked this out what would
you say to somebody oh first baby step
it's a thousand dollars enough you know
it's you got to remember this is
temporary Ken this is not a long-term
play and and it's good to have that fire
lit under your butt you know a thousand
dollars yeah you're you're feeling like
oh this is this is not enough it
shouldn't feel like enough it should
make you want to get that thousand
dollars saved and move so quickly
through baby step two so that you can
have that comfort and that security of
baby step three the three to six months
saved so no it's not gonna feel like
enough but it will be that's right
because you know I mean what's the worst
that could happen you know if something
goes out on your car and then as soon as
you have to pull from that you put it
back real quick that's right it works we
also had some really interesting
relationship money combos right where
we've got some spouses that uh they
don't trust each other no man and as a
result their struggle with money you
certainly get that uh interesting call
on finding accountability budgeting as a
single person right so uh that's
interesting when I don't have somebody
to have that budget meeting well it's
easy to get tempted and kind of skimp
because it's like well nobody sees me
changing the budget right nobody's
watching when you when you go over you
know and you make that purchase that
you're not supposed to make but you can
can get the right people in place that's
right get the right people and then how
about Real Estate in this crazy Market
calls on real estate should you think
twice before you buy a fixer-upper what
say you on that one you know I think
with this Market if you have if you have
the money saved right and you're ready
to make a down payment I say get in
where you fit in Ken oh see I say I like
that but I would think about it 72 times
not twice that's all I'm saying right
yeah I mean if you have some money if
you have the money it's like working for
my down payment right you can always
refinance if the interest rates go down
look at you I'm just saying uh I'd love
to see the tool belt that you would rock
you'd probably have like at all
bedazzled is what I said Ken are you
looking at me right now bedazzled well
I'm just saying you bring some Flair on
the on the on the work on the work site
uh we also had a great call on uh why
you can't mathematically afford rent
that's 50 of your home pay and we teach
about those percentages why do those
percentages matter Jade I mean we call
it house poor and I think a lot of times
people only think about it in terms of
their mortgage but the same principle
applies to even if you're renting I mean
the whole idea is we want you to be able
your biggest wealth building tool is
your income right so if you're throwing
away so much of it you're going to feel
house poor you're not going to be able
to do the things you need to do maybe
they're in some cases people are still
getting out of debt maybe they've worked
the steps out of order and they they got
a house first or they're just in a bad
renting situation if all your money is
tied up like that man that's a horrible
horrible place to be what we teach can
and this is it 15-year fixed on the
houses and you don't want your your
payment to be more than 25 percent and
the same thing applies with renting no
more than 25 percent of your take-home
pay that's your after-tax dollars all in
yeah good stuff and then uh capping the
week our annual giving show 2022 is
always powerful stuff so uh just a quick
kind of rundown of everything we've done
this week that's just a snippet and uh
wow good good week and we're going to
finish strong today a taking your calls
Triple eight eight two five five two two
five Chelsea joins us in Des Moines Iowa
Chelsea how can we help
seventeen thousand five hundred and
student loans and I'm debt free
I'm new to investing I've only ever
invested what my you know what my dad
gave me and told me for the first 500
but then after that it's on me I have no
idea how to invest so where do I go from
here that's awesome Chelsea number one
congrats on paying off the debt that's
amazing you know we're gonna celebrate
that oh yeah yeah we alarmed you a
little bit we're very excited we're
excited um have you done baby step three
yet do you have the three to six months
set aside
yeah I have three to six months okay do
you have three months or do you have six
months
um like about five months ago okay
that's good that's good and your single
single lady yeah
yeah single just renting an apartment
just renting an apartment with a job if
you can get it to six months I'd love
for you to get it to six months first
simply because you're the only person
floating your income and if something
were to happen you know that's the only
income you have so I'd love for you to
get it to six months so you're a little
bit more secure and then let's start
with baby step four like you said which
is putting aside 15 and you know the way
we teach it is is pretty simplistic uh
we want you to spread your Investments
over four different categories okay
equally spread so that's 25 and we're
gonna do that equally over growth and
income stock you might hear that
referred to as large large cap you maybe
you've heard that then we want you to
spread it over growth which you might
hear referred to as medium cap and then
we want you to spread the next 25 over
aggressive growth which is small cap
okay so the idea here is we're spreading
it around and then finally 25 to
International or what you might hear
sometimes they might say merging markets
it's not quite the same but
International so the growth in income
those are like your big companies you
know these are like the big boys they've
been around forever they've made tons of
money we know they're going to keep
making money it's not really uh it's not
as much of a risky play okay and then
you've got your medium cap or your
growth companies and those are ones we
know they're doing well and they've
still got some room to grow but we know
that they're bringing money in and then
the aggressive growth right now that's
like your smaller a lot of tech is
aggressive growth because they're like
really hitting the ground startups
they're doing well but you know we don't
they're a little bit more volatile so
you can see how it's we want a whole
that whole picture of the pie covered so
that we're not really putting ourselves
out to dry we're not putting all of our
eggs in one basket right Ken that's
right Chelsea so what you hear is a
philosophy there and that's what we want
that that strategy to look like through
mutual funds yes that cover all those
stocks that Jay just laid out so let's
start with what does your company offer
do they offer a 401k or a match
um no I'm on my own I just have my IRA
oh she's just into her Ira okay
fantastic all right so so Jade really
explained the the four areas and the
reason we do that and again we've Dave's
been teaching that for a very very long
time and so what we're doing there is we
are Diversified yes and it's a really
sound strategy so what we want you to do
now is we want you to go to
ramseysolutions.com and we want you to
click on the smartvester pro and in your
area we want you to sit down with two or
three smart master Pros who teach it the
way we teach it part of a teacher that's
right they're going to back up what Jay
just said but the reason we want you to
meet with multiple is because we want
you to feel good about the relationship
and the connection there because this is
a relationship you don't make any moves
unless you understand it that's right
Ken and but now she does because she
knows how it should be equally spread
good stuff hey very exciting Chelsea a
young lady who's got a great future
in her sight because of the financial
sacrifice and now you're ready to win
financially and you're gonna do it thank
you so much for the call don't move more
Ramsey show coming right up
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
I've got it for years I've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds Shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller Shades or even outdoor Shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey Show I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by Jade warshaw and
uh if you're new to Jade uh that's okay
because she's new to the show and she's
crushing it so excited to have her
joining our ranks of being a Ramsay
personality and Jade has lived
everything that Dave Ramsey has taught
for a long time so we have a lot of new
people coming in and out of this show
who may be new to Dave and we are part
of the squad here and Jade is amazing so
much fun and uh rocking some killer
kicks so maybe later in the show I'll
have her do a high kick we'll see I can
do one she's as cool as the other side
of the pillow and uh so it is fun a
little shout out to Stuart Scott uh rest
in peace one of the greatest sports
center anchors of all time that's one of
my favorite phrases all right hey
um would you believe
that it is possible Jade
if I told you that in about 15 minutes
and for only ten dollars you could get
self-aware to the point that you could
truly discover what you wanted to do
with the rest of your life would you
believe me if you're telling me Ken I
believe it all right well you can it's
called the get clear career assessment
I spent years living what is now this
assessment and then several years
developing it and it will give you a
very clear report on what you do best
that is your talent which you can turn
into skills it will give you a clear
report on what you love to do work that
you look forward to and and really lose
track of time when you're doing it and
then finally it'll
show you what motivates you
it's called Talent passion and Mission
and when all three of those intersect
now you know what your work purposes and
ultimately
greater purpose to make a great
contribution to the world so this tool
is now on sale for only ten dollars it's
normally thirty dollars now I'm gonna
tell you something Jade I don't I didn't
approve this that's a big sale that's
that's a third that's a third it's a
thirty dollar product we're giving away
for ten dollars for heaven six but hey
if you want to level up in your income
uh maybe make it a better move in your
career is the way to do it you can go
get it right now I'm gonna take it are
you gonna take it you should take it I'm
gonna take it and you can also bundle
that with my new book from paycheck to
purpose uh or the proximity principle go
to ramseysolutions.com right now and get
the get clear assessment for only 10
bucks ramseysolutions.com so go get it
all right triple eight eight two five
five two two five is the numbered South
Bend Indiana David is on the line David
how can we help
hey Karen hey Jade how you doing what's
going on David
uh kind of a it's kind of based on
careers like you were talking about uh
so I uh
recently I got a a great opportunity uh
at another company back in April I was I
was actually really happy where I was
but they weren't quite um
paying me was paying me what I what I
knew I would I could make with my uh my
education that I have and the experience
I have because I have a Six Sigma Black
Belt and um so this other company gave
me a call offered me 27 000 more a year
to come uh join join their uh join their
team so so of course I I did give my
employer at the time you know the
opportunity to counter uh uh make a
counter offer uh they couldn't match uh
so I ended up joining the new team uh
things were going really good
um but then we had some management
changes
um so long story short now so now I'm
kind of working as a say like a
warehouse analyst what I do is I just
kind of uh
track orders and why we're not getting
things to customers on time
um and the the thing is like now I
really don't have any purpose there is I
just kind of find out what's going on
every day and you know let them know
what's what the problem is and and I I
don't have a problem working for for
bosses that are younger than me
um except the the one I do work for now
is uh he's nine years younger and he is
a lot of experience that a lot of
development left in them and HR was
actually hoping that I could help
develop him
um and uh
so David I feel like I feel like you're
kind of dancing around the issue yeah
and I think you're trying to be really
nice
oh yeah and I hear two issues but I
really want you to tell me what is it
that you want help with today
I just don't know what I what I what I
need to do with my career anymore it's
just yeah I don't feel any purpose yeah
you took a page you took a higher
paycheck and you got no purpose good
news I wrote a book called from paycheck
to purpose and I'll give you that
um I promise I didn't put him up to that
folks that's not a paid plug but the
issue is is now we've got to figure out
what we want to do and then what you're
bringing up is adding insult to injury
and the injury is
there's no meaning in your work you got
no juice right is the way I like to say
it and so now you're going on top of
that they want you to Mentor a kid and
you feel like why am I doing that I
don't even like what I'm doing and then
I gotta help a guy who's younger and
more inexperienced than I am and so it's
just creating this frustration am I
right
yeah
and the other thing is like he doesn't
really want to take advice from me yeah
but here's the deal that's a non-factor
you don't want to be there correct yeah
you shouldn't be training your boss yeah
that makes zero sense so we need to come
up with an extra strategy that's really
why you called right hey Ken help me get
out of there but help me figure out
where to get to am I right
yeah I would say so yes you would say so
do you have a couple of ideas of what
you would like to do I mean you were
doing something before continuous
Improvement I mean I love I love
teaching people how to make their job
easier okay but you're not getting to do
that in this current role and
what's up you're not getting to do that
in this current role correct no not
right were you doing that in your
previous role
yes yeah
so there's a term for folks like you or
people that could beat you which is
boomerang employees where they go back
to their previous employer do you think
that's possible
their Market their their RVs so they're
actually at a dollar bio right now with
the economy and uh okay so that's not
what I'm asking you don't want to go
back there it's not is it possible so
you don't want to go back there so the
good news is we're going to go back to
your previous job and we're going to say
okay this is what I love to do I'm
essentially leading but the way that I
lead is that I want to be instructing
coaching that's what I heard and what
you said is that a true classification
for what I think you said
yes all right so where can I do that
and it's less about the industry it
doesn't sound like to me there's a
certain industry or a product or service
that you're fired up about it sounds
like to me you want to be in a
leadership position and and the work you
want to be spending most of your time on
is work where you are guiding
instructing mentoring coaching so that's
the job description
and it may not say it that way
but you got to dig into it in the
interview process of going okay this is
my style of leadership and I want to
come in and this is how I like the lead
and and so for you it's it's it's a it's
an open field out there you're not
sitting around scratching your head on
this do you understand what I'm saying
yes how are you feeling right now what's
your confidence level
well when you put it out that way I
think uh you got a lot more confidence
there it is what did we do there we got
clear
so David you got to stay in a place of
clarity all right that was a setup
question uh I was prepared to deal with
it Jade if he said he was not confident
but I thought he would be more confident
than he is and the reason David that
you're confident and I'm I'm reviewing
this because I want you to get off this
phone call and here's what's going to
happen when you get off this phone call
Jade I can tell you that fear and doubt
will present themselves in the days
ahead fear is I'm I am worried that
something bad is going to happen doubt
is I don't believe that Something Good
Can Happen David hear me my friend when
fear and doubt pop up on your shoulder
you've got to go back to this initial
conversation right here and you've got
to say here's what I know
I am good at leading coaching
instructing and guiding people is that a
true or false statement
it's true it's true
now we're going to move to I love
guiding and instructing and leading
people is that true or false
that is true and then we're going to say
I am motivated
to help people win
professionally and personally is that a
true or false statement
absolutely all right so what we did Dave
we just walked through Talent love it
what he does best passion what he loves
to do and in Mission what motivates him
so David we Retreat back to Clarity when
we are confronted by fear and doubt and
when that happens now you go okay I know
why I'm leaving
I know why I'm going over here and then
that will give you the confidence to
press forward and Jade here's the best
part there's three C's
Clarity leads to confidence and
confidence leads to courage you're
preaching Ken uh-oh I might need to take
an offering we'll see we better speaking
of an offering we pay the bills through
commercials got to do some of those and
we'll be right back
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
look I love real estate and I want you
to have a house but I don't want a house
to have you that's why you need to get
in touch with Churchill Mortgage to make
sure you do this right these guys are
awesome they'll help you get on a
smarter mortgage plan because they're
committed to doing what's right for you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice basically they care
that's why we call them Ramsay trusted
you can achieve debt-free home ownership
and Churchill is here to help go to
their site churchillmortgage.com Ramsey
to start your approval or get more
information
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the conversation here on the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
Ramsay personality Jade warshaw
and uh we're having a blast I'm gonna
tease this I don't know when we're gonna
do it at some point today but okay we
got the cool shoes on today we didn't
know we didn't know and uh we'll we'll
just we'll just the shoe game with Jade
folks well you know what I'll tell you
what I don't know if I'm gonna get to
that but I'll tell you what I do want
people to do is follow you on Instagram
at Jade warship okay
w-a-r-s-h-a-w and do you ever show your
shoe game on Insta sometimes I do I did
a giveaway last week I saw that we gave
away a pair of uh Jordan one lost in
football and I got jealous about it I
sit about 15 feet from me and I got all
nosy and I started getting a little
weepy and mopsy hey I tried to send you
a Michigan pair I'm gonna get it I'm
gonna get it Sam hit me up at the party
the other night about it too I felt
ghosted I'm just no just letting you
know no no no but anyway we'll but you
need to follow her on Instagram
um that's a good follow I would love uh
okay so it is time for our blinds.com
question of the day find out for
yourself whyblinds.com is the number one
online retailer of custom window
coverings you get free samples free
shipping and with the new promos that
run every month you'll save even more
use the pro promo code Ramsay to get the
best deal all right let's read today's
question it comes from Carter in
Washington he says I'm dealing with a
tricky situation and I don't know how to
approach it I'm 21 years old and in my
first year of working for Boeing the
income system works where I start at
twenty dollars an hour and at the six
year mark I will shoot up to 42 dollars
an hour the problem is my father who
essentially uh runs a factory for Boeing
and can get me straight into the
management starting at sixty dollars an
hour but but he thinks that this is
ill-advised because I don't know my
business yet and haven't built a
foundation through Boeing yet I feel
like if I become a manager now my
projected future could be so much better
financially management is salary so you
can be laid off whereas my current job
is union he wants me to max out the
Union first then shoot to management so
if I get laid off I can go back to a
maxed out union job how do I navigate
this oh Carter
slow down young grasshopper that's the
gist of my advice I mean it's like me
saying you know I'd like to I'd like to
make 10 million dollars now Jade well
done because it will allow me to do so
many more things right now Jade yeah I
want 10 million dollars now well you
know what I wanted to be able to dunk a
basketball all right I wanted to play
pro basketball well
I'm five foot eight and can't jump over
paper all right so we have some issues
there so the idea here is is while I'm
limited in my height and athletic uh and
vertical leap ability vertically
challenged yeah I employ in more than
one way uh with the height and the
ability to jump uh and quite frankly it
couldn't hit the three under pressure
but I digress the point is is that
you're young you're starting out your
first year make it twenty dollars an
hour bro that ain't bad dude are you
kidding me that ain't bad that's great
money my first job was 515 an hour come
on
I'm the old guy 425 an hour oh yeah in a
greenhouse in Virginia in the summer
holy moly and I was so little back then
I had to run around in the shower to get
wet yeah I didn't have much fluid to
lose and you're sweating like it was
crazy it was horrible
um my friend your dad's right don't
pressure your dad I hope your dad has
the Constitution to say no to you to say
slow down son yeah uh so here's the deal
you need to earn it and and you said it
in your in your question
um I just don't have a foundation and
you don't you don't have any experience
and you have a limited skill so pay it
now pay it now pay your dues pay it now
and then the next will take care of
itself so that's that's uh the extent of
my advice there Jade anything you want
to add to that I mean you you are a very
successful Entertainer before you got
here you know what it's like to pay your
dues you got to pay your dues you know
if you if you try to Sprint and Source
straight to the top there you're going
to run into so many situations that you
haven't learned how to handle yet and in
the end you could end up falling on your
face it's way better to just like you
said pay your dues and because you learn
so much as you go and you cannot skirt
that process don't don't try to skirt it
all right Britney's up in Raleigh North
Carolina Brittany how can we help
hi guys thanks for taking my call
um so basically I moved to Raleigh North
Carolina on this past March from
Pennsylvania
um and I'm ready to call Raleigh my home
and my lease is going to be up this
coming March
um the thing about it is I only have
about 15 grand saves
um I have no debt
um
and whenever I'm out looking at these
homes
my like monthly payments after all the
fees and everything's been added in it's
about two grand and I make forty two
hundred a month
and that is it's like almost half of one
that's like half of my pay right a month
um so
I'm like wondering do I rent
another year somewhat cheaper or do I go
in and buy something well I mean I'm not
like with the scenario that you
described which thank you for giving me
all that information so you've got the
five the 15K saved up we don't have any
other debt which is great
congratulations for paying off that debt
do you have three to six months saved
outside of this 15K because the way we
look at it is you've got baby step three
which is the three to six months and
then you've got the 3B where you're
saving for your home so I want to make
sure that the 15K isn't all the money
that you have in the world
it's online savings okay well it's a
great savings but let's call that your
three to six months is does that fit
into your three to six months category
like is that enough money for three
three to six months of expenses
um or would you need more
I probably would need more okay so what
I want to get you to Brittany is to the
most optimal place where you can buy and
it doesn't sound like you're there even
if you did have another three to six
months saved up and you had this 15K
it's not enough for you because your
payment would still be 2K and like you
said that's I mean it's almost 50 of
your take home which would make you
house poor at that time so I do think
um you know if you get back into your
lease what are you paying what are you
paying a month now
um 17. oh so you're you're not much
under it all right no and I've been
doing I've been doing fine like
but I just don't I wouldn't want to go
like much higher like so I would yeah
that helps me pay too but he's already
shown me he's not totally reliable so
I'm like going into this yeah you don't
want to depend on that that's like as if
it's by myself so what's the cost of a
home in Raleigh North Carolina that is
uh conservative based on you being
single so let's just start there and
back into this how much would that cost
what are you looking at
it's about 300 000. all right and so
based on again what Jade you would teach
on the 15 year mortgage 50 year fixed
mortgage you start running those numbers
just a ballpark have you done that on
today's uh interest rates there's
calculators out there we've got one at
ramseysolutions.com and you begin to see
okay what would it look like to have a
15-year and what kind of down payment we
want to say minimum 20 percent right uh
we want 20 it's this is her first time
home buy if she does 20 she's going to
avoid PMI your private mortgage
insurance but on a first time if it's a
little bit less that's all right you
know I I would do for sure Britney more
than five percent five percent or higher
because we want to make sure that we're
not that we're we're ahead of the game
when we get into it well the whole point
of this Brittany is to get a number what
does a down payment need to be because
here's the deal at the 15 000 you've got
saved up you're close to your three to
six months right you're really close
based on what your take-home is but we
don't want her your your emergency fund
is not your download no I know that I'm
saying she's got to finish the three to
six months she's close yes and the next
thing is 3B and so I want you to have a
really clear picture of what that number
is so if it's 30 000 or whatever the
number is so you're closer than you
realize but you've got to have Clarity
yeah on what that number is because
you're close to finishing baby step
three then it's I I'm going all in I'm
gonna get that down payment so you are
however long it's going to take you to
get that down payment is how long you're
going to be renting I also want to know
Brittany are you a TR on a trajectory
for your income to increase
possibly possibly something in April
might happen Okay let's work on that too
yeah yeah let's work on getting that
income up for a couple of reasons
because it sounds like you're going to
be renting a lot longer not a lot longer
but longer than you want and of course
it's already upwards you know close to
that 50 Mark let's try to get that
income up let's start saving for baby
step 3B and I you already know this but
we're not we're not depending on the old
boyfriend because
we're not going to combine our finances
he needs to put a ring on it if we're
depending on anything you know what I'm
saying if he likes it then he should
have put a ring on it that's what
Beyonce said there it is you say it's so
much better I could have sang it you
could have she is Jade warshaw I'm kid
Coleman this is the Ramsey Show
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsey show where we
talk about your life specifically your
money your work and your relationships
I'm Ken Coleman joined this hour by my
colleague Jade warshaw and we are having
a blast taking your calls the phone
number to jump in is triple eight eight
two five five two two five that's triple
eight eight two five five two two five
Jeff joins us in Cincinnati Ohio Jeff
how can we help
hi thank you guys for taking my call and
welcome to the show Jade thank you so
much of course yeah my question is uh
I'm currently considering changing
career paths and just wanted to see if
now is a good time to take that risk
given everything that's going on in the
economy or if I should kind of take my
grandma's advice and just be grateful
for what I have and kind of continue on
the path online now oh I think we have
some narrative issues I suspect there
are some narrative issues in your
question so what is the move that you
want to make that you think might be a
risk
it's time to be leaving and uh CPA job
for a financial analyst in real estate
okay and what is the supposed or known
risks from moving from CPA to financial
financial analyst if I can talk uh in
the real estate world
yeah I mean I know that real estate's
very up and down and you can kind of go
through cycles and I know from my
understanding in my experience at being
CPAs relatively uh one of the safer jobs
right is there a real estate company in
your area that you've got targeted that
you would love to work for
I have a couple yeah and I also do I do
real estate on the side as an agent okay
um and I've enjoyed that quite a lot
okay good well so we did see uh let's
call it about three or four months ago
Redfin a major uh a real estate
organization laid off a bunch of people
certainly we are seeing a what is a
housing recession there's no question
about that so the real estate market is
cooled and so there could be more
layoffs there but just because that's a
headline doesn't mean that's a reality
in Cincinnati so because you know those
two companies
um if for me I would be making
connections with people over there not
applying yet but making connections if I
know somebody over there or I know
somebody that knows somebody over there
I'd be finding out what kind of uh
financial situation are they in do they
have a good outlook are they in a hiring
freeze are they hiring right now I just
wouldn't rely on the headlines that
would be the first step have you done
that
I have and they they are hiring and
continuing to hire yeah
well my friend I gotta tell you see risk
to me is a loaded word
I think there are levels of risk right
so I would say low risk medium risk high
risk to keep it simple do you think
that this is a high risk move for you if
you were to move over into that world
I guess it's not necessarily the high
risk it's just the like the unknown
that's maybe concerning me I got news
for you
the unknown exists for everybody even
CPAs your CPA job isn't as safe as
grandma thinks it is
right okay yeah think about it so here's
the point if you have the skill and if
you have the passion for it I'd say go
go now but I mean there's no risk here
we're not jumping off of a cliff we're
literally moving from one boat to the
next boat here and uh you should do it
with two feet and just kind of Step
we're not jumping I don't think that the
risk is that high and I think you have
to go further into uh the process and
let's go interview and let's walk all
the way through it remember the
interview process is just as much for
you Jeff as it is for them and you can
ask good questions you can dig in a
little bit more but I think the real
estate market is here to stay I don't
think it's Doom and Gloom at all I think
it's slowed down and uh but I think it's
going to pick back up I think you're
gonna be fine
okay
yeah I appreciate that and I've taken
your get clear assessment as well and
that was very helpful did it validate
the work you want to do
100 it did yeah all right then so here's
the deal I'll leave you with this uh
years ago I had the opportunity to
interview Jim Collins
leader wrote good to Great built the
last and I was asking him about these
type of decisions I was like the unknown
the you know the fear of the unknown is
a big deal and I was asking him his
thoughts and he basically said this he
said he was uh teaching a business class
Jade at one point and at the end of the
Class A young man came up to me and said
hey I've got two opportunities that I'm
looking at and I want your advice one is
I go work for a major public company all
the things that come with that Big Brand
all the things right
or I go start my own thing that I've
always wanted to do and I could start it
from scratch now and and Colin said to
him he said well you're asking that
question in a way that leads to people
thinking that the the automatic decision
is the guaranteed salary and all the
things with the big companies right but
he looked at the young man and said you
have no idea what's going on with
management there and they could do one
thing and it could kill the stock price
and then everybody gets laid off and
maybe the company like Enron goes
completely like in a matter of days to
zero and he he said the young man he
said but you control your future oh come
on when you go do your thing and he said
it's like it's like paint by numbers
when we were little kids you got little
ones oh yeah they have paint by now the
paint by numbers is fantastic green on
two blue on three whatever yeah and that
is what we seek sometimes because it
feels like safety tell me what to do
when to do it it's more secure and yet
our best future many times is when we
just take a blank canvas and we paint
our picture oh I can attest to that you
know when Sam and I came out of school
you know with music degrees it was like
okay who can we go work for where can we
go do this and after a while it was like
you know I think we can create our own
thing and create more security for
ourselves and it really just depends on
the person and by the way I think
everybody's entrepreneurial yeah but you
did we did explain it I want people to
hear that well you know what we did is
we started out working for a company and
I I I felt controlled yeah and I thought
you know what I can do this myself and
so that looked before we were contracted
to do other people's shows yeah and I
was like I don't want to do other
people's shows I want to do my own show
so Sam and I got together and we started
creating and then we started shopping it
out it's about again knowing the right
people forming those relationships and
saying here's my product I think it can
really value you and I think we can
serve you in this way and I say all the
time you've got to approach the market
from an attitude of servitude this is
how I can help you yeah this is how and
and of course you're going to be helping
yourself as well that's just a byproduct
but when you serve people well the
byproduct is you're gonna make money
that's right you know if you set your
prices right and so that's what we did
and then that that migrated into the
next thing it started with us doing
shows and then we thought man we can
help more people by us getting jobs for
them yeah so we started a talent agency
after that and we said all right we're
gonna we're gonna put other musicians
that want to do their own thing and find
work for them so I think that when you
start out it feels uh overwhelming
because you got this just this blank
canvas there did it feel risky at the
time
um and if it did on what level it it
didn't it felt riskier to not do it oh
that because say we gotta unpack that
what were you risking had you not done
that
now that you're on the other side you
know I think and I'm not again everybody
might not be this entrepreneurial path
but for me and for Sam I know we had a
vision for something we wanted and by
not doing that we were forsaking our own
Vision if we had said you know what uh
it's too risky it's too hard and here's
here's the thing we may I mean I gave
you the short version we made plenty of
mistakes along the way we we did one
thing where we invested a bunch of our
own cash and and tried to get these
other shows up and running and it fell
flat on its face so I'm not negating the
failure aspect of it because that's the
part that everybody feel fears yeah
moving forward you've got to keep going
you got to keep going because I can
honestly say and look back and go all
right no regrets yeah that's the word no
regrets all right so I think what you
and Sam were risking and what
Jeff risks and we all risk if we do not
do the thing that we know we're supposed
to do it's regret we risk getting to the
end of our life yes and looking back
with soul-crushing regret and even I
want to get to the end and reminisce
even not the end of the Latin you got to
be able to sleep tonight well you got to
be able to sleep at night you know and I
mean I agree with that of course you get
to the end of your life but a lot of us
we we well tossing and turning tonight
because we we're in a situation that's
right but the idea is we're risking
regret and let me tell you something you
want to truly find the definition of
unhappiness oh it's regret it definitely
is and and oh yeah you know and so I
love this Jeff listen Jeff Now's the
Time and Jeff let's play this out
because Jade was right there is failure
in her story failure my story good
gracious I know right talking about when
I started in broadcasting at 33 I could
tell you all kinds of stories but I'll
tell you this
you will always be moving forward even
if it doesn't work out you take this gig
and it doesn't work out you've moved
forward yes now we may need to Pivot
left or pivot right but we're still
moving forward so Jeff the answer is yes
do it switch today now seize the moment
take it and take a step forward with
boldness and Watch What Happens Jade
warshaw great hour always good to be
with you my friend I think James and the
crew behind the glass for keeping us on
the air and mostly America we want to
thank you this is your show this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
foreign
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world to get
your daily dose of advice on life and
money check out all of our shows from
the Ramsay Network wherever you listen
to podcasts
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsay
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about life
specifically money work and
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined
this hour by Jade warshaw we're taking
your calls we're up here for you and you
matter deeply we want to get you some
clarity some hope and some breakthrough
today triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Jade you
ready to roll I'm ready let's rock all
right before we do I do want to tell all
you fine folks that are listening or
watching if if this show is encouraging
you entertaining you equipping you in
any way we need you you are the greatest
marketing tool in the world word of
mouth so would you share the show uh
review the show uh subscribe to the show
however and wherever you listen that
would do us a huge favor we want as many
people as possible to know there's a
positive safe place to have a
conversation about moving ahead in the
most important areas of your life thank
you for considering that uh let's this
is fun let's go across the pond shall we
London England where Franklin is joining
us Franklin how can we help
hi uh so I was born and raised outside
of the States you know just to give you
a background and um essentially I don't
have any kind of uh credit history in
the States but I'm moving to the states
in a couple of months for work and I
essentially wanted to find out how best
to build my credit score as quickly as
possible for you know obvious reasons
why you need a great credit score and
the fact that I'm looking to get into
real estate investing
um and so I just wanted to get any tips
that you would have in this regard
that's cool Franklin uh thanks for
calling uh are you familiar with the
Ramsay show are you kind of like a first
time listener how'd you find us
so I listen occasionally I I I I I
haven't you know streamed it or called
in or listened live yeah mostly YouTube
videos and on um uh Instagram and and uh
essentially with snipe it so that okay
internet okay well you know on here we
teach things a little bit differently uh
we teach to get rid of the credit system
and and to to to get yourself as far
from the need of a credit score and
credit as possible our whole thing here
is paying off your debt so that you
don't have to in building up money so
that your credit score doesn't matter so
I just want to take a moment and kind of
give you that Foundation because if
you're kind of listening here and there
you might not have the whole picture so
I kind of want to give you that picture
so that you don't feel like I'm coming
after you because it might sound like
I'm coming after you a little bit
Franklin but I'm not I just want you to
kind of see where I'm coming from so we
believe that the debt score or the
credit score I should say is nothing
more than a I love debt score it's
basically measuring how you interact
with debt it has nothing to do with how
much money you actually have and I think
that frankly you coming over here to the
United States the whole point is you
want to create this life you want to
make sure the money is good and the
money is Flowing but the credit score
has nothing to do with that so the way
we teach
is that the best way to financial pieces
like this a series of baby steps all
right the first baby step you're getting
a thousand dollars saved the second baby
step is you're paying off all of your
debt except your house the third baby
step after that is you're saving three
to six months of finances and then you
go on to investing baby step four and on
up to baby step seven where you're
giving generously you're buying real
estate and cash you're doing all these
wonderful things so I think that right
now we're not having a meeting of the
minds so I can't tell you what to do and
I won't tell you what to do to improve
your credit score but I will tell you
what to do to improve your relationship
with money and to manage your money to
the optimal degree does that sound all
right
yeah yeah it does okay I guess
and maybe this is uh uh jumping too far
ahead but I guess my question would be
if you're because I'm again I'm I'm kind
of learning the ropes out to real estate
investing and one thing I've come to
understand is if you want to uh um do
deals a lot of deals um as quickly as
possible it's not very tactful to uh
save you know it sure it is sure it is
like yeah it is look at we're trying to
get you to a point of Building Wealth
with as less risk as possible and I know
there's a lot going out there zero down
you know all these different ways to
purchase real estate uh but that's
ultimately that's not the best path and
it's the the most the path that's filled
with the most landmines all right and
we're trying to get you there peacefully
we're trying to get you there safely and
uh here's the thing Franklin you're
going to do what you want to do on this
this but you called us
and so we're going to tell you that if
you're purchasing real estate outside of
your personal primary residence that you
need to pay cash for it and save up to
pay cash for it and if you follow the
baby steps you will be able to do that
how old are you
I'm 31 now dude you're young let's work
these baby steps and let's work them in
order do you you're coming over here
when you come over here what's the plan
are you um I mean do you have debt now
no I don't no debt now do you have three
to six months saved up
yes I do you do excellent what's the
professional goal when you get here he
wants to be in real estate uh
so uh so the real estate thing is going
to be my side hustle or I'm uh currently
a lawyer okay um
and I'll be working so you'll be working
as a lawyer yes and what's the income
um
uh somewhere along uh into six figures
apart
it's about it's just below 200. okay all
right so here's what I wanted to say on
this because Jay's absolutely right but
but Franklin if I told you
that I had a strategy for you to build a
house this is a house you're going to
live in in the United States and I told
you that I had a strategy that would
allow us to build the house in 30 days
like really fast but it was risky would
you be in for that plan
I might no you that's why you're
laughing come on man it's okay to say
you painted me in a corner Ken would you
be up for that strategy Franklin this is
your house
that's what Jade's telling you you watch
all these Instagram videos of people
saying hey you can get in and make all
this money
that's the quick plan but it's also
crazy risky am I right Jade oh ken
you're I mean that's what I'm trying to
help him see what you're saying here
like this is a side hustle why would you
take on something Franklin that is so
risky when you can do it the right way
on the side and as a lawyer You've Got
No Cap to your income
but that's what I'm telling you Jade has
laid it out for you if you work these
steps you're going to be able to do this
Franklin keep going I mean you got
you've done it all you've paid off your
debt you've got that three to six months
man just start saving to pay cash you've
got a good income
the American dream debt Freedom that's
the American dream you're coming over
here I'm letting you know that's the
dream the dream is not having a bunch of
real estate debt I'm telling you laying
it out there all right now coming up
next we're gonna get to more of your
calls and we'll reveal
what uh Jade and I got right today about
our outfits and didn't know that's
coming up don't move this is the Ramsay
show
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
Christian Health cost sharing Ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981. we believe you
should have the freedom to focus on your
health while being supported by a
community of Believers giving you the
opportunity to create many more more
verse
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show where we
talk to you about your life specifically
your money your work and your
relationships I'm Ken Coleman joined by
Jade warshaw and this is kind of fun
today we had a little bit of a switch
our good friend George camel with a k a
little under the weather today oh man
didn't feel like he could go he was a
game time decision it was and we got the
email moments before I was wrapping up
the Ken Coleman show and I got the email
you'll be joining Jade warshaw and to be
honest with you since George is not here
I don't mind saying this is a real
upgrade for me and uh and so no I love
George but uh really excited Jade
warshore if you're new to Jade or new
the show she's our newest Ramsey
personality she's an absolute freaking
rock star and she's a great cook and uh
she she has a great story and then on
top of all of those greats can't she's
got great shoe wear and I you know I get
a lot of grief around here for for my
attention to clothing and shoes and so
the point is is that we didn't know we
were going to be on the air together
today yeah both rocking the
monochromatic look we are I got the all
gray on head to toe you're all black
head to toe all black but it's the
Footwear come on Ken don't make me put
my foot on this table because I'll do it
you're younger than me show for the now
for the listening audience they can't
see these are the Classic Air Jordans
our viewing audience could see those
things right there I believe I can fly
yeah there it is folks
um that wasn't bad for not practicing oh
yeah that was good was I on key yes okay
very intimidating all right so I'll show
my kicks let's see these what is this oh
wait a second well they are Nike
these these came from Forrest Gump
notice the socks too I think I think
these were the shoes that Forrest Gump
was wearing when he was running across
the country thank you Jay thank you I
don't know if that's an insult but we'll
take it I mean but then we got the cool
kicks on today oh yeah I once saw you
wear all white oh been known to do that
many times and I said this guy this this
guy this is a different guy right here
one swaggy dude is what you really
thought no smoother than a fresh jar
Skippy wow wow I'm gonna take the rest
of the day off I don't even know what
that means hey I will say this one
little fashion tip uh and this is this
is for men and women monochromatic is a
win I'm gonna tell you why it points to
the shoes so you got to wear good shoes
if you're gonna go monochrome yeah
because it's like a giant arrow pointing
down to the accessory so the reason we
both have those shoes see maybe you
haven't thought through this but I have
the monochromatic outfit points to the
shoe Ken do you know who you're talking
to I'm sorry I thought I now somehow
offended you and don't slap me well let
me tell you what else you need to think
through when you're picking out your
clothes what is it in the budget oh now
you get these shoes on a budget don't
you I do you know my husband resells
Jordan so he sometimes people see me
wear shoes and they're like oh my gosh
and I'm like y'all don't understand I
didn't pay like I didn't have to pay
like that but you got a budget for this
stuff and and don't go broke for a label
please do not go broke for a label
people no no no you got the envelope you
got it you gotta put it in the line item
yep but uh just because you're on a
budget doesn't mean I'm speaking to guys
only right now you can't look like a bum
all right oh you better not show up
looking like a bomb Oh that's what I'm
saying all right there it is we're ready
to get to the phones Joe is on the line
in Jersey City New Jersey Joe how can we
help
hey Ken hey Jade how are you guys we're
having a blast as you can tell what's
going on
uh well I just wanted to say Ken great
stuff as always and uh Jay
congratulations and good luck hey thanks
Joe
uh yeah so my question is um now that
the market has kind of gone you know
Wayward over the last few years with the
pandemic and everything and inflation
and um uh cost of living and all that
has kind of gotten up in almost the
entire country just wondering does have
you guys considered has Dave considered
the um emergency the starter emergency
fund to go up maybe to like 1500 or 2000
because some prices for things like a
hot water heater or transmission
whatever might be more expensive than it
used to be on the Euros a book
originally he started this plan now this
is funny Jade this is like does the
emergency fund baby step one need an
inflationary adjustment very thoughtful
question well let's say well whose side
are you on here Ken what I didn't take a
side I just said it's a very interesting
question everything else is hitting
everything else is being adjusted for
inflation I think it's a thoughtful
question it is a thoughtful question and
and here's where I'm gonna approach this
because you're not the first person to
ask this Joe and I'm sure you're not
going to be the last person to ask that
question but what we have found is that
when we ask when we teach for folks to
get a thousand dollars saved most people
and I mean the statistics will tell you
that 56 of Americans do not cannot
afford a thousand dollar that's right
emergency wow and we actually did a
study on the state of personal finance
and it told us that 36 of Americans
actually have zero dollars
zero zero some might call it a goose egg
no money saved so if you have a thousand
dollars do you know what that's called
Joe that's called winning at life
because most people just don't have it
so where I can understand the mindset
because trust me I have kids you know we
got cars we got there's a lot that can
go wrong and I understand that but
understanding what the what the averages
are and understanding what the actual
truth of the matter is which is most
folks don't have any money saved if they
have an emergency they're going straight
to their credit cards all right and
they're taking an emergency and just
turning it into a even bigger problem
with zeros on the end and so what we're
trying to teach is is an accessible way
for you to plan for emergencies and
we've found that a thousand dollars is
something that if you bust your butt and
get it saved it's actually enough to to
float you through now here's the thing
it's not intended to feel like all right
I've made it in life I can just sit back
and put my feet up put my drawer put my
Jordans up on the desk right there it is
that's not what it's for you know we
want you to feel that that that anxiety
not anxiety but we want you to feel that
that feeling of I got to get out of this
like this is not where I want to stay
and that should light your fire to get
through baby step two so that you can
have that three to six months and have
that cushy feeling and that that
wonderful feeling of security how does
that sit with you Joe
no that's uh that's fine you notice I'm
I'm kind of getting started with the uh
baby steps I've known about it for a
while but um you know the wife and I
would you know trying to come to uh
understanding an agreement on how to how
to go about it and yeah we haven't even
just talked about this uh step number
one and I know that um my wife might
feel more comfortable as Dave always
tell us about the security gland oh yeah
yeah he's gonna come up and I think you
know I just want to have an idea so what
would be said Hey Joe I presented the
whole baby stuff to her she kind of
likes it but yeah yeah let me ask you a
question how much debt do you have to
pay off uh-huh
uh quite a bit I got about
um my wife has uh under her name but
Cyrus obviously I understand that um
it's that uh oh just under 900 000 I
think in uh student loans um and then we
have about maybe uh another 30 ish in um
credit card or uh Consumer Debt so I
want to address your wife's Comfort
gland because you're bringing up a very
good point and you're gonna have to
communicate that she's got to be on
board so I want to give you just
something from a husband's point of view
on that conversation so let's just
forget for the moment the hundred
thousand in student loan debt let's look
at the credit card debt or Consumer Debt
of 30 000 okay if you were to pay off
one or two of those credit cards okay
how much money would that bring back to
your budget so in other words how much
you paying out on the thirty thousand
dollars what would you say ballpark
figure of the thirty thousand not
student loan how much are you paying out
each month in minimum or whatever
oh well uh well without the mortgage
it's try it's about uh like
1500 all right that's what I'm looking
for on mine yeah all right so my point
is if you guys got really intense and
you paid off thirty thousand dollars
that's fifteen hundred dollars a month
that you don't have to put out you
understand what I'm saying it's a mental
thing now we want you putting that money
into the student loan so you're gonna
debt snowball this thing but I'm just
trying to help her see we're gonna have
more you have more than you think you
got more than you think once we pay off
some of the debt so the safety gland
needs to be focused on whoa we need to
build up some protection and the
protection is not the savings the
protection is getting rid of the debt
that's the it I'm not trying to play
mind games with your with with you and
your wife but she needs to understand
why we need to be all in on this yeah
have you guys done Financial Peace
University
uh I I went through I would do some of
the classes I haven't gone through the
following um and my life is going to
yeah I want you guys to go through that
together and that's going to get her on
the same page with you because that's
key
if you want to get this debt paid off
you wanted to be on the same page
Financial Peace will teach you how to do
that
good stuff thanks for the call you guys
can get there Joe hang in there all
right she's Jade warshaw I'm Ken Coleman
this is the Ramsey show more coming
right up
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
this is the Ramsey show where we talk
about your life specifically your money
your work and your relationships I'm Ken
Coleman I'm joined by my colleague Jade
warshaw this hour triple eight eight two
five five two two five is the phone
number to jump in triple eight eight two
five five two two five uh Jade I got to
get something off of my chest here oh
boy and curious to know your thoughts on
this yeah this is going to be a little
spicy particularly for men so dudes
you're just gonna have to handle this
because I'm coming at you this is a big
build up well it's distressing headline
uh that I looked at and it's coming from
a new study from the Federal Reserve
Bank of Boston
men are dropping out of the labor force
because they're upset about their social
status
I'm just gonna let that sit for a second
I don't know that I've read a more
pathetic headline in my lifetime I'm
going to say it again I want you to hear
what it really is saying the headline is
men are dropping out of Labor Force
because they're upset about their social
status
what it should say is men are quitting
because it's not going the way they want
it to
oh man
I'm not making as much money as the
other guy so I'm gonna go home and live
off a mom and dad
yes snowflake you wimp
what is happening here all right now
before I go further into Data I got to
take 30 seconds on this and some of you
are going to say oh you're old school or
you're a boomer well number one
yes I am old school number two I'm not a
boomer I'm proud member of Generation X
whatever the crap that means I've never
understood what that means but let me
tell you something you know where this
starts it's generation a total
generation where we try to make
everybody feel good and we gave
everybody a trophy or a participation
ribbon for showing up
and I got news for you people this is
what happens when we try to make
everybody feel good and we try to avoid
having them feel the sting of loss I got
news for you
there's first place
and then there's loser I'm just being
honest first or last well but listen
you're saying well kill what about the
Olympics I got they got the the the gold
medal the silver medal the bronze oh
these are Olympians who work really hard
we should acknowledge first second third
place but in Youth Soccer when the score
is five to nothing I got news for you
little buddy you lost
you lost five to nothing and by the way
the five-year-olds know these kids are
smart enough to realize that the ball
went in the other team oh they win in
our net twice and we haven't even
sniffed the other side of the field and
you want to know what Ken they can
handle it they can Jade they can handle
it these kids are resilient but these
dudes can't and that's a shame now
listen folks here's the data
um
the study found that the decline in
earnings for non-college educated men
over the last four decades has increased
their likelihood of leaving the labor
force by nearly half a percentage point
now
this this might hurt some of your
feelings but I I can say this
younger white men in particular were
more likely to leave when their expected
wages fell relative to their more
educated peers but
while the white men are whistling out
turn turns out the ladies aren't Jade
tell us women have not seen the same
level of decline in their wages based on
education
wow that group has seen a 32 increase in
weekly earnings now there's two things I
want to get at first we have a culture
that has created this context what do I
mean very simple
we have for decades said that the
college diploma is the most desirable
way to live a life in other words if I
have a college degree I'm going to be
more successful and so the numbers have
borne out that way because companies
play the game too right oh you don't
have a degree but the bigger problem is
we have men that are leaving the
workforce all together they are taking
their ball and going home you didn't
pick me so I'm gonna go home and Mommy's
gonna make me feel better and cut me a
PB and J sandwich and let me play on the
video games all day long I'm telling you
what's happening oh I'm just I'm just
keeping her not my son's kin not myself
I know better than that and and not my
brothers
you know what and here's what needs to
happen here's the fix there's not a
policy in the world that's going to fix
this yeah this is a social problem and
I'm trying to have a little bit of fun
with it but I'm making a key point if
you are a family member if you are a mom
or dad a grandparent a brother a sister
a cousin a good friend and you are
harboring and I'm using that word on
purpose yeah you are harboring a
wussified dude who's got his feelings
hurt and refuses to go work and be a
productive member of society it is
incumbent upon you to kick their butt
out okay
I'm just telling you it's a problem Ken
give me some dap I don't even know what
that means but I'll do it what's the
debt is the DAP is I'm with you I'm with
you heart and spirit see folks I'm
getting cooler by the minute all right
now now I'm gonna go home and do that
with my 17 year old kid he's Gonna Roll
his eyes so hard they fall out of his
head you know what do you think about
what I just said and I'm not looking for
approval no this is a societal problem
it reminds me of okay I mentioned
earlier Sam and I have a talent agency
and we we book Talent all around the
world yeah and to get the job there is a
series of protocols you have to follow
and I find Ken because America is the
greatest country without saying but it's
cushy up in here a very good it's cushy
in comparison to some other countries
right and what we find is that if we're
uh hunting talent in let's say the
Philippines or or India where life in
some areas is not as cushy when we tell
them this is what you have to do to get
the job they do that thing Lickety
jump in Jack Flash they get that thing
done whereas some of the counterparts
who are here in the states they could be
a better player they could be better at
the job but they don't feel that they
should have to do yep and so they they
and they sleep on it and I'm like now
wait a minute now what's going on the
job is the job but I think what happens
is you get cushy you start having
entitlement you start having this I
deserve mentality and I think that I
deserve mentality can be it can it can
be the beginning of the interest it is
and you've nailed it so you all kind of
so those of you that roll drives and
laughed at my whole thing about a trophy
but see this keeps getting
um it keeps getting supported throughout
where I show up and I'm rewarded for
showing up just for showing opposed to
getting rewarded for accomplishing right
here's what happens these men are
falling out of the workforce because
they look at the competition and they're
getting beat and instead of rising up
and going all right I'll get you next
round you know what they do they go I'm
just leaving all together you know why
yeah because they've been protected from
failure that's right and failure
best I can tell Jade with every
successful woman or man in the history
of the universe failure is what
propelled them forward you can't learn
to ride a bike without wrecking a bike
it's necessity
and I'm telling you we have protected
our kids from failure and as a result
they've got no grit so what happens is
we coddle them until they get to the
real world they fail that's right they
feel like a failure because he's making
more money than I am right and so they
don't know what to do because they've
got no grit they don't know how to act
if you find anybody who's successful and
I'm not talking about you know at the
very time I'm not talking about the
Michael Jordan's I'm talking about Ken
Coleman if I talk to you a successful
man good at marriage good at their job
you you will list out you could probably
make a whole computer list of all the
ways that you didn't get the trophy all
the things that you endeavored at and
failed at hey I got told by a program
director in Atlanta second year into the
chase folks guy looked at me and said I
don't know why you're trying to get on
the Sports Talk station
this is a number eight market and he
said this I'll never forget he said Ken
you don't have the talent to make it in
a number eight Market oh yeah oh yeah
I've been there let me tell you
something I did and I do and here I am
Come On Son but listen it hurt
I know I did I have a little bit of fun
but I'm not puffed up I'm telling you I
went home and it rocked my world to hear
that oh yeah but somewhere in the next
48 to 72 hours I had to decide come on
it's about what you're gonna do come on
nobody's gonna hand you anything
snowflake like you got to get out and
take it it's like that old trick when
it's like you getting ready to open the
door and then they drive forward again
try it again yeah that's it you know you
know I talk about this all the time to
my boys and they're sick of me saying it
but you know I'm trying to teach my kids
you're in a competition
and if you don't think you're in a
competition I got bad news for you
you're getting your head beat in you
don't even know it you're competing
against the U of yesterday and you're
competing against someone else now not
in an ugly way I'm not telling you
healthy competition you're trying to
book artists come on and there's always
someone there's always someone who's
practicing more than you that's studying
more than you there you better believe
it while you're complaining they're out
there getting better yeah well good
stuff there all right I feel much better
coming up next a question about saving
for retirement or future education will
break that down this is the Ramsay show
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
taking your questions about life
specifically your money your work your
relationships this is the Ramsey Show
I'm Ken Coleman joined by Jade warshaw
and uh you've probably heard the words
inflation and layoffs and recession and
blah blah blah blah blah all over the
place used as
what I like to call negative bombs just
to get your attention so you'll watch
the TV a little bit more the truth is
you can't control what's going on in the
white house but you can't control what's
going on at your house I'd love for you
to think about and actually join me Dave
Ramsey Rachel Cruz Dr John deloney Jade
warshaw uh and Chris no no you're
shaking your head why are you shaking
your head I don't know if I'm gonna be
part of this one all right never mind
this news to me I'm making stuff up it's
not in the car no no no you're right
you're right you're right what do you do
you do man I thought I was saying
nothing wrong I'm saying something wrong
no no no no keep going keep going
building you are gonna be there
all right I'll be there all right you're
gonna be there it's gonna be fun here's
the deal uh we want you to uh check out
the website ramseysolutions.com events
for our continuing uh event series The
Tour is Building Wealth it's going to be
a national uh here uh at our uh I
believe here at our headquarters it's
gonna be fantastic January the 12th
thank God you said that was right that's
right Indianapolis Indiana on February
16th Austin Texas oh now you're there
would you pipe down please Austin Texas
February 23rd Salt Lake City I'm gonna
pay for that one Later Salt Lake City
Utah April the 24th Anaheim California
May 2nd and uh this is a wonderful event
we're gonna teach you how to inflation
proof your money build lasting wealth
and invest wisely general admission
passes start at just 49 don't wait they
will sell out all of our fall Building
Wealth events did sell out and these
will too again go to ramseysolutions.com
events that's ramseysolutions.com
um slash events are we on the docket
together are we serious what cities are
you we're going to be in Indianapolis
and Austin together
oh okay very yes yeah no no actually I'm
in Austin in Anaheim oh so you and I
will be together in Austin okay okay
very good it's good all right well we'll
get our schedules uh figured out on the
break but the great news is we are here
for you let's get to the phones triple
eight eight two five five two two five
is the phone number Hannah is up in
Ogden Utah Hannah how can we help
Hi how are you we're having a blast
what's going on
so I am a long time listener I've been
listening to probably before I can
remember my dad really likes Dave Ramsey
and has encouraged me and my siblings
through the baby steps and I've done
that good for you I am 26 years old I'm
debt free except for my mortgage
um
my husband and I bought our house back
in January of 2021 and so where we're at
right now is
um I'm making enough money that he's
going and doing a career change he's
working part-time and getting his
education so he can do his career change
and make more money okay
um I'm contributing all like I'm maxing
out my retirement at the company that
I'm working with right now okay and my
question is is I would eventually like
to not change careers but go and get
further education in my industry and
um so my question is is do I keep
putting the money into the retirement
fund or should I take it out and invest
it in a different way because I know
we're probably going to have to move
um what's the education what's the
education that you're pursuing and what
do you think the ROI is and then what is
it going to cost so it's a three-part
question
um the education I'm looking for will be
a um I work in compliance
um and so it will be a master's degree
in Environmental Compliance type setting
um it the way that the industry Works um
it is set up that a master's degree is
um required to so it makes it easier to
climb up to certain levels so there
would definitely be a return on
investment and then the company that I'm
working with right now also has
um
they will help pain so what would be
your cost what would be your cost to get
this Masters
my coffee was Master
Ed my income at the time because working
full time and doing a master's degree
would be like I know who I am I know
people who can do that I but I can't
um so I need a little bit of a cut and
income would probably have to move to be
closer to the school that I want to go
to
um and Dollar Wise how much is it going
to cost
per semester
first semester about 6 000 per semester
before any assistance from yeah you're
making it too complex what is your
out-of-pocket total
not per semester
total okay
um probably 20 000 okay that's our
number so I just wanted to give that to
Jake yeah it's twenty thousand now I
want it before I give it to you on the
money piece I do want to cover this
the school I want to go to
that's a very concerning phrase I agree
Hannah nobody and I mean nobody gives a
crap where you get your Masters you just
got to get the Masters and it feels like
to me we're we're adding extra Hoops to
jump through when we're considering
selling a house moving somewhere to go
to a school that I want to I'm going to
challenge you on that and you don't have
to respond because I'm not trying to put
you on tilt but I just want you to know
nobody cares last time you went to the
doctor you didn't ask the doctor where
he went to med school or she went to med
school right so I'll just leave it at
that Jade but now we know we got twenty
thousand she's got to save for the cash
flow of the master and this is for the
entire year
oh my goodness you can cash flow this
what's your income right now
my income right now is 60 Grand a year
um and then like I mentioned my husband
is working on a career change that'll be
done probably in the next six months or
so and so he'll be making equivalent to
that as well so are you asking about the
the the investing question because you
feel like it's going to take you longer
can you keep investing as we teach and
still get the 20 saved up or is it going
to take a really long time
I mean that's 800 that's 833 a month
if we just broke that out over two years
you got 833 a month that you need to
save what let's work it backwards what
do we need to do because it I mean if
you don't have that money yet to start
this coming semester that's okay you
know the house is not on fire what do we
need to do to make this scenario true
for you to where you're saving up that
kind of money so that you can cash flow
this and actually make it work out and
not stop saving for return and not stop
saving for retirement because I did want
to ask you more about that but I mean I
know that you're maxing out your 401K
but we really want to get you to the 15
so if you're not at 15 we want you to
get there and then we can start working
on what does it look like to be able to
pay
for this as we go
you know and I think I think that you
can
I think if you find the right the right
um school that's within your budget
because again Ken gave great advice
about making sure that we're not just
you know choosing a school based on the
name or based on what what quote they
say but picking a school that's actually
in line with your budget so you can get
this Masters and you know 20 you know
the 20 000 number that gets you to 833 a
month but maybe there's something out
there that you can do that's less
expensive I don't know
um is there online options that are less
expensive I know I know there's
something out there that's going to work
for you it's just a matter of you know
turning enough door handles until you
find the one that's got the prize behind
it you know what I'm saying
yeah yeah do you feel that you can
keep investing as Jade instructed and
save up for the master's program
be a little bit easier once the career
change for my partner
yeah okay that comes to fruition all
right we'll be patient be patient I'm
not in a hurry
be patient so I think Jade what you and
I are saying is don't interrupt the
investing I don't think it's necessary
no let her husband finish his career
shift and then let him get stable let
the income kind of you know let
everything settle out and then we start
the journey and during that time you're
researching right we're not just sitting
around you're researching what your
situation is going to look like and
you're starting to plan out and then
plot that forward and then when he's
done then it's your turn you know and
you guys work the plan you guys are
smart
you're very smart you've made great
choices up until this point I love that
you said that you're not in a hurry
[Music]
what it takes to win absolutely keep
investing and Jade's right the full 15
percent you're gonna love her for that
advice many many years from now so keep
it up Jade warshaw always fun to be with
you my friend great hour I want to thank
James and the Hardy fellas behind the
glass for keeping us on the air I want
to thank you America for listening this
is your show this is the Ramsay show
foreign
ER you can find all of our shows with
the Ramsay Network app on your
smartphone it's the only place to listen
to the entire back catalog of episodes
download the Ramsay Network app in your
favorite app store today
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
live from the headquarters of Ramsey
Solutions broadcasting from the PODS
moving and storage Studio this is the
Ramsay show it's where America hangs out
to have a conversation about your life
specifically your money life your work
life your relationship life those three
areas are
inextricably connected and I'm telling
you if you're losing in one of them
you're gonna end up losing in all of
them you cannot separate those areas so
we're here to help you with Clarity and
next steps so that you have hope to get
the transformation you're looking for
I'm Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
Jade warshaw she's just all sorts of
fabulous in all caps our newest Ramsay
personality you need a follower on
Instagram at Jade warshaw don't forget
the H it's not Warsaw it's War Shaw
that's right I just love the shh part or
Shaw it used to be warshovsky really but
it was cut short no kidding yeah I
learned that all right I mean it's my
husband's name but you know yeah all
right well we'll talk about that the uh
you know in the area over there uh but
hey there's a number to jump in if you'd
like it's toll-free triple eight eight
two five five two two five triple eight
eight two five five two two five let's
go to the Big Apple New York City New
York Josh is on the line Josh how can we
help
hey good afternoon guys uh so nice to
get on the air first and foremost I want
to just thank you all
um follow the baby steps and I'm
officially debt free hey baby Stacks
nice six and seven uh so my question is
kind of an interesting uh a positive
dilemma so I've been with my company now
for four years I've been going in during
the pandemic love what I do I work in
human resources and I recently was
tapped on the shoulder by leadership to
take on a director level role uh the
role is going to be remote
I've been going in I've never worked
remotely and my question really is
pretty simple it is
um I know you know Dave and you guys
talk about remote workers and kind of an
economy now first ones to go uh my
company doesn't have any indication of
any layoffs but just kind of wanted some
advice on that
um it's a great opportunity it's going
to essentially close to double my salary
and uh you know put myself in the
Financial Freedom for myself and my uh
six-month-old daughter uh and you know
her financial future so just wanted to
know your advice on kind of working from
home jumping into that especially in the
economy we have now and what are your
thoughts on that yeah well the work from
home is not the biggest issue here and
I'll get to that and explain that in a
second the question is what makes this a
great opportunity beyond the fact that
it's a big Financial bump
um added responsibility and really be
able to influence uh folks like I said I
work in human resources and I love I
have a passion for people and kind of
building them up and this will really uh
help me create the programs I want
um at a you know with a much better
bigger table you really love the work or
really enjoy it
I do yeah does it produce results that
motivate you
it does all right check check
um and I so that leads us to so first of
all that's what I would call The Sweet
Spot like is this the sweet spot for you
feels like it is and it feels like it's
also the right ladder for you this is
going to provide you an opportunity to
keep climbing yes or no
I would say yes
um definitely yeah definitely over the
years 100 so this has got all of the the
check marks that I want to see because
I'd only ever want anybody to make a
move just for money because that wears
off pretty quickly
um and I love that it's got a ladder for
you that's really really good so this
gets back to the remote piece
um are they requiring you to work remote
or is it just one of those
classifications where this is a remote
job I mean how's that being discussed
from leadership to you about the nature
of the remote work
uh so I think based on the position is
it's more of a uh the reason for remote
is it has travel involved so you know
I'll be traveling to different areas
around the country uh where the
locations of the company are great um so
you're actually not really remote you're
going to be with people most of the time
in front of them yes or no
yes I don't have the exact details on
how much it's uh you know about 20 to 30
percent travel so I won't say all the
time but definitely a good chunky okay
so that's the good thing because I could
just tell you you're a dude who loves
being around people right
I do all right that's the only red flag
here is how much time are you going to
be around people
and so we uh we understand you can get
the details on this how much they expect
you to travel obviously when you're
traveling to be around other offices
you're going to be around people but
when you're not traveling and and you're
at your base presumably in in New York
City or the surrounding areas
you know what's that look like and and
would they allow you to come in and work
in the office do they have an office
location
they do I haven't asked that question uh
ask that's that's an yeah yes I didn't
even think of that way here's what this
is going to turn into you've got to find
the balance between flexibility and
autonomy which is what the remote job
implies when you're not traveling so
we've got let's just make this up let's
say 20 of the time you're traveling so
that leaves us 80 so of the 80 when
you're not traveling using this just
example and then you go okay well could
I come in 40 50 60 70 of the time I
don't need an office but is there a
place where I could work where I could
be around people you have to answer the
question how much do you need to be
around people and I can just tell you
some people are cut out for remote work
some people are not and I think you have
to determine what are the negatives to
not being around people Jade I mean you
and I are both well I shouldn't say that
I'm a people person I don't do well
alone my wife and kids go out of town
I'm I I'm just I'm just a disaster oh
yeah not only that but you know some
people struggle with the the remote work
because it's it's all on you to make
sure that you're getting your things
done that's right that you're putting
those systems and I came from remote
remote work I mean I used to work from
home do you do well with it I do
um do you have a preference oh you know
I really enjoyed working from home but
the drawback on that is your home even
if you have a home office your home
becomes your place of work and so it
makes it very hard to turn off number
one and then you've got all the
distractions but um you know I I can do
both of them but I do think if you can
have a dedicated place that you're going
into yeah so how does it feel Josh
because when you called you wanted
advice should I do this and and when I
when I get a question like this I just
know you already had an idea which way
were you leaning before you called
I think I um I was leaning towards kind
of the remote piece right giving us the
opportunity but you know you guys gave
me some great advice because of asking
the questions of yeah I listen I don't
see any reason why you wouldn't do it
the only red flag is your soul right
you're a people person so you know what
you're gonna have to just mitigate for
that and you can do that you can figure
that out they'll let you come to the
office some and hang around great or
make sure that you have some friend
lunches built in you know something like
that you know hang out with some dudes
every Thursday we're gonna you know
we're gonna get together after work and
watch Thursday night football or what
come up with some rhythms so that you
have that personal connection I think
that's the only thing I'd be watching
out for yeah you can you can get
isolated fast you know my husband works
from home and you know sometimes he'll
just take his he'll take his iPad he's
out there working in the lobby now we're
watching us right now yeah he'll go
somewhere where there's people you know
so that that's the play yeah that's the
play
um is is to do that to make sure man I'm
feeling lonely I'm feeling disconnected
oh yeah and so I need to do something
about that and I think that's the key
and in any job you want to find out as
much as possible before getting into it
I think that was another thing you
highlighted yeah ask the questions yeah
but hey excited for you Josh the best is
yet to be looks like you got a great
track and I'm really happy for you thank
you so much for trusting us and calling
in all right she is the fabulous Jade
warshaw I'm just Ken and this is the
Ramsey Show
[Music]
oh
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back to the Ramsay show America
I'm Ken Coleman joined by my colleague
Jade warshaw I like how I said that
towards the end of the last break the
fabulous
Jade warshaw I'll take it yeah uh it's
true we're having a blast triple eight
eight two five five two two five is the
number triple eight eight two five five
two two five if you've gone through
Financial Peace University chances are
it's because someone in your life told
you to do it maybe your mom and dad gave
you two years a gift maybe your pastor
offered it at your church or it was just
that friend that just kept kind of
nudging you
until you did it now you can do that for
someone else this Christmas give someone
Financial Peace University share the
same hope that you have discovered now
when you give Financial Peace University
as a gift they're not going to just get
the course they'll also get the premium
version of every dollar the world's
greatest budgeting app
and group coaching with our team of
financial coaches now that truly is as
Cousin Eddie said in National Lampoon's
Christmas Vacation that truly is the
gift that keeps on giving all year long
there it is yeah you know what I'm
talking about all that in a bag of chips
yeah you know we should have added to
this the one thing that would have made
this gift giveaway I mean not a giveaway
but this gift for you to give away would
be to add a yule log with FPU carved
into the log can that would have been
great everybody loves a nice Yule Log to
burn on the fire nobody is doing that
nobody's you yes I love a good fire you
were at my house the other night I was
we have a we have a guess uh I mean an
actual wood burning uh fireplace yeah
and maybe we should have used it because
I struggled with getting that that fire
pit going for us hey hey I want to get
you a yule log all right so just just
just you know just if you give me a yule
log
I'm gonna put it well you're gonna burn
it is what you're gonna do I thought it
was food no oh they've turned it into a
dessert it's an actual piece of wood
it's a tradition long-held tradition
okay yeah I thought it was a just Google
it hey but if you want to give Financial
Peace University away to somebody we've
got you covered go to ramsesolutions.com
give FPU that's ramseysolutions.com give
FPU there you go so yeah a lot of people
right now by the way it has become a
dessert but it was not a dessert it's a
tradition so look it up I'm speaking of
dessert the team is like feeding their
face oh we're trying to help America
they're eating behind the uh and they
know how I feel about that they know
that food is the way into my heart
they're they're killing me back all
right tell you what we're gonna do save
one and I'm gonna sample whatever it is
in our next segment I'll it doesn't look
like there's much left well just hang
tight everybody all right let's get to
the phones Aiden is on the line in
Charlotte North Carolina Aiden how can
we help
yes thank you so I'll give you a little
back story
um first of all uh thank you so much for
what you guys have done um you've
changed my family tree wow uh back in
the day my dad started spu I think 12
years ago and now they're doing amazing
um I am currently 16 years old
um and so still in school obviously
and my question is I have a job
opportunity that I could go take next
week if I wanted to and we didn't know
if it's better to just simply drop out
of school start working get these next
few years in early and then later on get
my GED and go from there what's the job
it is uh so it's a stone manufacturing
company so like the fake stone that um
you see on walls and stuff it's not
really fake it's a Concrete that's kind
of painted I guess yeah and they create
those those uh Stones is that a job that
puts you on a ladder to climb to where
you ultimately want to be my goodness
you're only 16 and I love that you're
thinking about this but where does this
put you long term if you were to go now
or two years from now
so yeah so it would give me
um just a head start that uh is what I'm
looking at it from and yes I could climb
and you know there's definitely
opportunities for raises and bonuses no
I'm not asking about financial I know I
can hear you man you you are a 16 year
old kid who's got dollar signs roll
around in your head and your dad mom
done a great job by teaching about money
I get that I'm not talking about
financial because it's indisputable that
if you go if a 16 year old starts
working out you're ahead of every other
16 year old I get that I'm saying does
going in this job at a stone
manufacturer is that your dream is that
where you want to be
so not officially but it would get me
closer to where I want to be eventually
which is what
um I want to get into business of
business ownership and real estate okay
so first of all Aiden I love you man but
uh and I'm the guy if there was anybody
that ever
would say it's okay to drop out of high
school I'm the guy well I'm the girl
because I do it oh it freaks parents out
I'm freaking people out right now I'm
not telling anybody to drop out of high
school but we would not drop out of high
school
unless we were making such a huge
strategic decision that you had to take
at the time and the reason I say that is
and by the way I think I think High
School like I'm the guy that goes 16's
probably old enough let's let him
graduate I would reform and totally redo
the education system I'm not going to
get into that Aid and that's not why you
called I'm just saying I'm the guy
that would be most willing to give you
the advice to do it in this situation
I would not do it and here's the reason
you have the financial education your
mom and dad have done a great job
setting you up to win your head is on
right as far as thinking about the
future and finances but we live in a
world still where there is a stigma and
there's stigma's on a lot of stuff that
shouldn't be stigmas but there is a
stigma on
the GED yep there just is and in this
case the
uh return on this decision right you
hear about return on investment well I
like to talk about return on a decision
if I'm decided to do this
versus this I want to know yeah that
there's a huge positive return and I
don't think it's positive enough I'm I'm
guessing your Mom and Dad aren't really
thrilled about the idea either and the
job connection the job connections you
want to own your own business one day
and you want to get into real estate you
know what I think you ought to do Aiden
I think you ought to stay in school but
I think you need to get hooked up with a
real estate professional maybe a
developer maybe a builder maybe a
world-class real estate agent and do
everything you can with them if they'll
give you a part-time job doing grunt
work do that yep if they'll let you
Shadow them do that because if I know
it's 16 a Direction I want to go I want
to get in proximity and I'm going to
give you an early Christmas present it's
the number one best-selling book called
The Proximity principle which says Aiden
in order to do what Aiden wants to do
he's got to be around people that are
doing it and in places where it is
happening my good friend Jade knows this
formula she's used it it's simply this
the right people plus the right places
equals opportunity Jade absolutely I've
seen it I've seen it in full effect Ken
and I think that if Aiden kind of holds
his horses here and plays his cards
right like what you're saying uh I think
he's gonna see it yeah work for him too
you know he's he's got a lot of time
he's got a lot of time but I am so happy
to get a call from a 16 year old okay
who's thinking big Jade yeah he's got
his head on straight his parents see
this is not one of the whiners that we
talked about early on this kid's got his
head on straight he's right he's willing
and and ready to work I love that I love
that man he's a young man I I almost
he's a little boy man he's a young man
you know because he's thinking big
picture and I love this but yeah here's
the deal for for young people listening
um and Jay you know you talked about you
live this when we make a decision
please look at it from every angle oh
yeah and it's not about getting ahead in
the now
the decision must be about getting ahead
in the next and he's thinking now and I
love this kid he's 16. but he's going
well I just make more money for two more
years well the negative of that decision
outweighs the positive of having more
money in his account you know uh there's
this teaching that I heard
um a while back I've heard it many times
it's called the 2020 approach and uh
back in Florida at our church this this
couple used to come Mac and Julie
Richard and their whole thing was
parenting and they used to teach 2020
parenting where it's parenting for the
the 20 minutes or 20 years and that
approach that's it that approach Works
in so many other ways when you're
thinking about career when you're
thinking about your money it's so
important to think about the 2020
approach am I making this decision
that's going to feel good for the next
20 minutes that's going to be convenient
for the next 20 minutes or am I thinking
about the next 20 years that's 20 20
thank you Mac and Julie Richard wow Lake
Hills Church she's Jade warshaw now you
know why I say she's fabulous I'm Ken
Coleman and this is the Ramsey Show
don't move
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you are listening to the Ramsey show
coming to you from our Ramsey Solutions
worldwide HQ
in the Nashville Tennessee area and the
last segment of Jade and I are trying to
by the way Ken Coleman Jade warshaw with
you this hour and the last segment we're
trying to help people and do what we do
this whole show is about helping people
win with their money their work their
relationships and the guys in the
control room passing around a plate of
cookies like we're not here like how am
I supposed to concentrate and deliver
wisdom I got my cookie so what did you
have you ate yours during the break oh
no you have a morsel left what did you
so anyway they felt guilty and James
sent him in during the break what did
you get I gotta
I got a sugar cookie okay so look at
this guy so if you're if you're uh just
listening I've got a chocolate cover
looks to be like Ritz crackers and I'm
gonna I think I know what this is oh
that's gonna be good
oh yeah
somebody's cringing right now that hates
the sound of chewing I don't care this
is two Rich crackers with some peanut
butter and chocolate covered in other
words
this is deliciousness
oh delectable all right while I finish
smacking all right uh you know what I
love to give away besides cookies oh
food you know that's the way to my heart
and um with less than 10 days until
Christmas the Scramble for last minute
gifts is in full effect whether you're
on short on time which God knows that's
the case I got kids or budget we've got
a few DIY gifts ideas for you in our
newsletter this weekend guys we have a
newsletter here that we send out and you
guys need to get involved with that for
example how about hot chocolate on a
stick for your kid's teacher or whoa
time out what is that how does one do
hot chocolate on a stick I bet I could
figure it out
I bet it's like well don't withhold I'm
asking you what is it this is well this
is the way Jade warshaw would do it I
would get those pretzel sticks those
long the long thick ones and then I
would melt some dark chocolate and dip
it in there and then let it dry and then
I dip it in there again let it dry to
where we get a lot of layers on it it's
too healthy no star chocolate and then
at the end I'm not done yet Ken at the
end dip it in peppermint oh and then all
you've got to do is get you the hot milk
and not dairy milk because I gotta do
the plant-based milk and when it's nice
and hot put it in there it'll start to
melt and make sure you're entirely too
healthy nobody wants plant-based milk on
their pretzel
you would be you know what I read a stat
that said most people are lactose
intolerant they don't even know it let
me tell you since you're speaking in
third person let me tell you what Ken
Coleman would do can I get the same
pretzel Rod all right and I would just
swirl it around in some thick white
chocolate baby why is it gonna be white
chocolate candy
tell me why is it gotta be white
chocolate oh would you let me would you
let me read this yes okay for example
how about hot chocolate on a stick for
your kids teacher or I like this one a
photo collage for grandma or maybe a
basket a farmer's market goodies for
your neighbor that's a good idea if
you're on the hunt for the perfect
personalized gift we've got 15 count it
15 DIY gift ideas for you in this week's
edition of the Ramsay newsletter so if
you're not subscribed yeah simply sign
up at ramsesolutions.com newsletter to
receive the email newsletter on Sunday
guys we just solved your all your
holiday problems just write that just
just like that
we taught you how to make it oh man hot
chocolate stick and while you were doing
that I had the rest of the cookie oh
cracker or whatever it was so it was
just delicious just just hey if you're
looking to do something just combine
milk chocolate and peanut butter
and it's gonna be you can eat that
straight out the jar you don't even need
to I'd eat this pencil if you put enough
chocolate and peanut butter in this
pencil I'd get it down I promise you
that right now all right let's go to
Pensacola Florida where Nicole joins us
Nicole how can we help
hi Ken hi Jade
um so I am just looking for some advice
we
um cannot currently afford a house where
we're living but we love the location
and we love our church and our families
here so we're kind of trying to decide
whether we stay with family and save up
until we can't afford something in
Pensacola or if we should move somewhere
a little bit more affordable
well
you know there's a lot to consider here
so the the house that you're looking to
buy how long do you think it would take
you to save up to to be able to purchase
the house the way that we teach which
just to give a quick refresher that
would be a 15-year fixed mortgage where
your payment is no more than 25 of your
take home in your payment that's
including all of the insurances uh
everything uh is not more than 25
percent of your take-home pay so have
you done the research do you know how
long it would take for you to save up to
get something with those guidelines
um
it would take us uh probably another
year
before we would be able to have enough
down I think
um to meet those guidelines and do you
have kids you have kids
yes I have two kids under three oh two
kids under three girl I feel you
um what's the relationship like with and
not just your relationship but your
husband everybody what's that feel like
a year feels like a long time to me I'm
not gonna lie but some some families are
different like a long time
um
everything
oh I'm sorry no go ahead go ahead I'm
listening to you girl
oh okay
um so we we are happy where we're at
right now we can stay here for another
year while we save up and really get
after it but at the same time
um the housing market still kind of
feels a little bit crazy into this
specific area just because it's close to
a navy base there's a lot of remote
workers that want to stay at the beach
so we haven't felt any type of dip or
anything here okay just kind of seems
really far out before we would be able
to find something price wise that we
could handle well you know have you you
know I'm always up for a good Adventure
you know have you looked around to see
because you know I understand like when
your family is in one place and your
church is there trust me I get it my
family just up and moved here to
Tennessee we were in Florida for the
past 15 years family there our church is
there that is not easy I I sympathize
and empathize with you majorly but there
is something to be said for taking an
adventure especially actually if the
adventure could mean you reaching your
goals sooner if it means you being in
the type of house that you want to be in
sooner and the good thing here is it
sounds like I mean do you guys have the
sort of jobs that you can you know right
what what's your what's your careers
so my husband is in the medical field
and
um his company that he works for they
have been like exploding since the
pandemic which I know is not really a
good way to say it but he could move
throughout the country and I am a
stay-at-home mom retired or not retired
but I was a teacher okay and so Nicole I
have a question I'm listening in here
and I have a question because when you
set it up the way you set it up
you've gotta you've got an idea in your
mind as to where you could move where it
is more affordable how far away is that
I don't know actually well we kind of
talked about moving to North Carolina or
down to Miami why North Carolina why
Miami yeah
so North Carolina my husband has some
family up there and
um
Miami because he could move up in his
company a little bit quicker if we move
down there how big of a how big okay we
only have about a minute so we gotta
hurry here how big of a bump would it be
if he took the job in Miami yeah because
Miami is expensive yeah
uh probably 20 000 which would put us
about medium income down there yeah it's
not enough it's not enough space to move
so here's the thing it feels like this
entire conversation is we gotta move
somewhere where we can buy a house and I
don't think that's the right motivation
I really don't and I also think you guys
got some more investigation to do I I'm
looking at uh 30 to 45 minute radius of
Pensacola and I'm gonna go looking
online and go look at real houses what
if we move just far enough out to where
the housing was more affordable but we
could still see family easily and even
make that trip to church I just think we
got to look at that first before we
think about North Carolina for the sole
reason that he's got family there that
worries me oh yeah and I want to make
sure she's got the baby steps in line
too I want to make sure she's done baby
step one two three have three to six
months saved and that you've got three B
in place before you start buying houses
out in this piece Nicole let's go look
let's go see I like Jade's advice on the
adventure my just be 45 minutes away we
can make that sacrifice to get in a
house and still be a part of our church
family love the question I think you
guys need to do some work on this but
you'll get there don't move folks more
of the Ramsey show right around the
corner
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
welcome back America you are joining the
conversation about your life your money
your work your relationships here on the
Ramsey Show I'm Ken coma joined by my
colleague Jade warshaw our scripture of
the day comes from Philippians 2 verse
4. Let each of you look not only to his
own interest but also to the interests
of others our quote from Simon sinek the
true price of leadership is the
willingness to place the needs of others
above your own the phone number to jump
in is triple eight eight two five five
two two five that's triple eight eight
two five five two two five Atlantis
joins us now in Atlanta Atlantis how can
we help
oh hey guys
um I was calling to get some advice
um I met a real crossroads right now uh
about how I should handle
um some major uh events and assets that
I have I have a house
um that I purchased in 2020
and um at the time I was making more
than enough money
um I was right at the poverty line
making close to 40 000
um at the time and over the course of a
year last year I got uh into accident to
where I wasn't able to work at my
construction job where I was earning the
income to pay the mortgage and the bills
and
um I kind of just tried to take a leap
of faith and I got about three months
worth of uh living expenses in 2021 and
just tried to start
um my own my own career as a full-time
artist and that lasted uh just so long
to where I was able to um
pay my bills and pay my mortgage and
when the money started slowing down I um
got lucky and got a settlement check uh
right at the top of the Year okay what'd
you do with it
I uh I blew it I I'd say that I'd say
that
um fortunately I was able to pay off my
car note
um with it I paid down some credit cards
but how'd you blow it what do you mean
by that
so I went on a lot of vacations this
year
um
awareness this year I I had I had been
uh dealing with a breakup okay okay
all right Bud Mama Jade trying to go off
right now all right buddy all right we
got it we gotta deal with this thing
head on I I'm I'm gonna I'm gonna put
you through the ringer here for a minute
I'm gonna ask you some questions because
I want to get to the I want to see
what's really going on and I know you're
a little bit in your feelings right now
I can tell so I'm just gonna just cut to
the chase how much money are you earning
now
uh I'm earning uh about uh maybe 16 an
hour so that's that's and this is steady
this is steady work
yes so what's your time I'm only
bringing in I'm only bringing in about 2
400 a month okay
thing one this is just top top drawer
right here we got to increase the income
and we're going to come back to that but
that in your mind right now that's thing
one next thing how much I want to know
your total debt not with the mortgage
but just your total debt that you've got
on your plate right now
[Music]
um so I have about eighteen thousand
dollars in debt
um I also have
almost twenty thousand dollars on
student loan debt on top of it okay so
we're looking at 38 all right and that's
it that's all the debt in the world
besides the mortgage
okay so here's what I want you to do
thing one is we want to get that income
up okay because you got a little bit of
a an issue here and you've got debt and
we need a bigger shovel to help clean it
up faster and I it kind of feels like
your income right now is also not stable
I is that is that true is this is this
very true are you back in construction
no I'm not I um I
recently was just scrimmaging trying to
find
um anyone who was hiring so I'm working
a warehouse uh Warehouse support right
now first of all there's no shame in
your game that's at least getting back
all right but what I'm asking is is is
are you physically able to get back into
the construction work you were in before
and does it pay much better yes then
then let's go yeah let's let's game by
the way I'm gonna give it back to Jade
she's gonna walk you through this but
but I'm gonna tell you right now you're
working two three jobs yes you've
already vacated enough after the breakup
my man all right yeah it's time to uh to
work two and three jobs we're talking 60
hours a week because Jade he can do this
oh you can do this if he increases his
income Atlantis I need you to get on a
budget that's thing one because it
sounds like right now you're just
spending you're just out here living
what you thought was your best life
turning out to be your worst life and
you need to get control of the money
that you do have and make sure that
you're telling every cent where to go
because you've got a mess to clean up
here so I want you to walk through the
baby steps the Baby Steps step one I
need you to have a thousand dollars
saved do you have any money saved
no okay we're gonna get a thousand
dollars saved right away I don't care
sell something do whatever you have to
do but get that thousand dollars saved
and we are not touching that Landis
unless it's an emergency and I can tell
you what's not an emergency going on a
trip to the Caribbean that is not an
emergency okay taking a girl out to
dinner not an emergency get that
thousand dollars saved and then I want
you going into baby step two only and
only after you've got that thousand
saved I want you paying off every single
cent of debt except that mortgage using
the debt snowball
I'm going to explain that to you debt
snowball you're going to list all of
your debts it sounds like you got two
here from smallest to largest and we're
going to make minimum payments on both
of them but any and all money that you
can find because remember we're working
60 80 hours a week right now so all of
that extra money is going to the
smallest debt gonna knock it out you
gotta move quick with this lannis I feel
like you're a little bit you know wacky
wavy right now but you got to get laser
focused and get this debt cleaned up and
then after that we're moving on to Baby
Steps three getting three to six months
and I'm gonna hold off right there
because I don't want to overload you but
I do want to make sure that you get into
Financial Peace University okay because
that's what's going to walk you through
this for the Long Haul so my guy over
there Austin is going to talk he's going
to talk to you after the call and he's
going to make sure you get Financial
Peace University and in the meantime
step two so Step One is we're getting
solid work we're working step two get
that budget okay I want you to start
your budget I want you to go online
write this down everydollar.com and I
want you to download that today this is
how you're gonna get your budget and I'm
telling you this is so easy it's going
to walk you through exactly what to do
so that you can plan out Landis how
you're spending your money because
that's going to help you see you might
have you know you might look at that
budget tonight and be like oh my God
like every month I'm going over are you
using credit cards right now
uh credit cards are maxed out cut up
okay we're cut cut them up don't get any
more because we see that's not working
for you okay if we want different
results we're gonna have to do something
different and today is your wake-up call
how old are you
I just turned 28 28. okay you got time
buddy you do Lance you got another lady
or you you're still single
uh I do have a lady me and Molly got
back together but I'm more focused on my
son I got a I got an eight-year-old son
okay there's your why there's your y
right there yeah so I gotta make sure
I'm making them proud
well first of all first of all you make
him proud just by being dad all right so
these financial decisions that you've
made they do not define you my friend
and uh I I just want to make sure that
you're focusing right now on this
financial path that Jade laid out for
you and and not trying to save your
relationship wounds I'm glad you and the
lady are back together but let me tell
you something she better be on board
with this yep okay yep because if she's
not she's holding you back I am
promising you so we gotta and I'm not
trying to get in your relationship
because you didn't ask but I am saying
that eight-year-old son it's not about
making him proud because of who you are
it's being able to take care of him
provide for him and teach him through
through the Journey you're about ready
to go all in on I mean all in are you
willing to go all in lannis like Jade
has challenged you to do absolutely
absolutely well dude I mean you need
some juice man yeah you start acting and
talking and sounding like a guy who's
got an eight-year-old boy that he wants
to take care of that he can take care of
and then get your back straight a little
bit come on this is the locker room
shaming your game lannis come on Elena
someone ask you one more time are you
willing to do what Jade has laid out for
you to do
absolutely all right we putting our
hands in the center got some juice now
he's got some juice he got the juice he
can do this that eight-year-old boy man
I'd have a picture of him everywhere I
go put it in the wallet I'll take care
of my boy
I love it Jade warshaw that was fun it
was fun all right you'll come back
you'll do it again with me come on let's
do it all right very good I want to
thank James and the crew for taking good
care of us want to thank you America for
being with us this is your show this is
the Ramsey Show
[Music]
hey folks Ken Coleman here did you know
the Ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
Ramsay Network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
foreign
[Music]